[Music]
hi everyone so the talk is about
bitcoins a sinc IO and WebSockets and
and I changed the title last minute and
it kind of a it's self-explanatory at
the end of the talk
not at the beginning so I want one going
to into details so my name is Giovanni
this is my twitter handle
Oh born and raised in Italy well somehow
I became doctor in theoretical physics
here in in in the Netherlands afterwards
I was a PowerPoint to wizard at KPMG or
monkey depending on on your point of
view and now I'm a senior shoe designer
dollar-driven so if you come work for us
I'll design a pair of Nikes here for you
with the colors of God as driven I'll
say it once maybe but we're hiring so
drop us a line if you want to work for
us what this talk is about is a side
project that I did to experiment would
find new things in Python and at
Techland it's something that you can try
at home if you don't double with real
money if you do with real money please
I'm not responsible for for any loss you
might have although I will see you later
but a friend of mine actually made money
with a tool that I built and I'll show
you this representation so it's a real
thing
how many of you knows what I think I oh
yes yeah so maybe half off of the of the
audience basically it's a it's a new
model module introducing Python 3.4 to
write single threaded concurrent code
using co-routines
it supports pluggable event loops and
ships with one that we will use in this
talk and since python 3.5 we also gained
some new keywords to work with a sync
i/o and particularly asynch and await
keywords
course I talk about I'm talking about an
event loop but what's an event loop well
imagine you have a friend and you're
going to give the a list of tasks to
this single friend single as single one
that's married or not any Handy's friend
processes the tasks sequentially but
each task you give to your friend can
say well do a and then wait a minute and
then do B and our friend has the power
to do a and then start with the next
task in the queue which is not B because
that with we we told them well wait a
minute before doing B at the end of the
minute B would gets picked up and it
would be done by our friend so basically
we have the illusion that our friend can
do things in parallel well it's not
really impaired alone he's just doing
other things while he's waiting but we
as programmers or as usual we have the
impression that things happen in
parallel or concurrently because it
seems not like he's doing multiple
things while he was waiting
of course our friend is a Python program
using a sink io that's why I use it
instead of they of course it is stupid
why should we want to wait time between
doing a and B we want it done as soon as
possible but the reality is of course
that usually we when we write our
programs we wait on input output so we
wait on the database we wait on the
network we wait on the disk we wait on
other things and we eat huh and the idea
behind I think I own that we don't have
to keep waiting for this thing to be
done we can do other things while we
wait for this input output from from
these other systems of course you want
to see the code how does it look like
so basically this is that one of the
simplest example that you could do with
our sink I owe you import it and then
you write a function which looks almost
like a normal Python function
but it has a sink as before the depth to
indicate to the interpreter that it's a
function that is well basically it's a
Cortina or task a function that plays
with our event loop and then you can use
a weight a weight here is kind of
fundamental because your weight part
basically cuts the function in two
because once we reach the await our
event loop will say okay now I stop for
the right part of the line to be
finished before continuing so basically
you give your dysfunction to a friend
his friends start to to do things up
until he finds a weight other way this
stops doing things it start doing other
things that have nothing to do with
function and when the right part of the
line returns all gives back something
then it will start again and since here
I've wrapped it in a while basically
goes back to the while then he continues
and you're stops again wait one second
does other thing
thanks to me during that one second and
then he goes on so this is the function
and here I kind of create my loop just
like well boilerplate and then the next
call it's a blocking call which will
return only when my display date
coroutine or task is finished and at the
end I can be I can be polite and close
the loop so if I execute this code you
will see that this is the output between
one invocation of time and of now and
the next one there's approximately
should be approximately one second going
on yeah yes sorry I was looking at the
millisecond so it's a it's a indeed it's
a approximately one second between one
go in there and the other one but of
course it is even more useless because
if I just want that I can just write
this function here without no I think I
Oh
and he basically does exactly the same
thing in wage one second and he print
and it prin the current time well of
course he's only useful if you have more
than one task going on if you have a
single thing and single threaded and you
don't need code you don't need a sink IO
but let's say I want to do two things
concurrently
I want my display date and I also want
to call my hey function so you can see
the hey function they want to say
something but they can never they can
never say it in one in one go because
the other function the display date will
disturb him and so if we if we run this
code here who basically said this first
go hey
then there's enough time for a display
date to be to emit twice then the hey
hey function will go on and so on so you
can see how it's how my well these lines
here geez give us the impression that
we're doing things in a in a concurrent
way well in a parallel way what is doing
really concurrently well enough I think
now Bitcoin whatever done with Bitcoin
oh so I don't want to offend anyone with
Bitcoin or crypto explanations here I
want to do something fun and get a bot
that collects data from Bitcoin
exchanges and basically signals winner
an arbitrage open up so even if you
don't know what what an arbitrage is I
will explain it more at the end but
basically what we want to do we want to
do market neutral trading because if you
follow a bit in use Bitcoin is very in
stable currency and if you own Bitcoin
you're exposing yourself to market risk
so you're exposing yourself to Bitcoin
going going up and down by maybe also
several thousand several thousand
dollars per day what we want we don't
want to do that we don't want to risk
our real money so what we do is that we
will short sell along by bitcoins in the
exchanges
opens up an arbitrage possibilities
again I will explain the short selling
and buying later but basically you're
not actually selling and buying bitcoins
but you're selling and buying the risks
that Bitcoin fluctuate in price later
things will will be clear but the core
thing is that you do not have a risk on
Bitcoin fluctuations and you can still
make money if you want a longer
explanation either way at the end of the
talk or you can go here to this get up
issue of Blackbird there is a number of
Bitcoin exchanges that we can pull to
Paul to see if there is a if there is an
arbitrage opportunity so basically an
arbitrage opportunities that we can buy
from one exchange at a low price and
sell on another exchange at the same
moment for a higher price and we take
the delta minus the transaction costs
the exchange we can used a while for
example kraken bitstamp GD x bit bitonic
and draw more but i want to concentrate
to two exchanges that offer WebSocket
support so WebSockets who knows what
WebSockets are now so even even less
than I think I obey cyclists akut is a
protocol that enable interaction between
the client and server with low overhead
and real-time data transfer in both ways
and of course this is much better than
pulling from an API continuously because
if you pull on API let's say every once
every second the price could change
between one call in there in the next so
you lose some data there while if you
use WebSockets the exchange notifies the
client either price change is a trade
made and whatever and every time you use
a Jupiter or Jupiter as some people say
you're also using WebSockets because
Jupiter uses WebSocket on the on the
background so
we said that we could have an
architecture with looks like this we
pull from our exchanges here I showed
GDX a bitonic because they're two that
offer WebSockets client we could have
our code here the PI data sink insert
that takes the data put into the
database and then we could have an
emailer which I won't talk too much
about here but that looks at portraits
and every time an arbitrage opens up it
sends an email
WebSockets in our sync i/o are actually
a match made in heaven because if I
would if I would well if I would look at
this code here like when I make the call
and then I say well wait one second
between the disco and the other one
otherwise we'll get blacklisted by the
exchange or whatnot I could write this
one here but I just say well I'll wait
that the WebSocket connection sends me
some data just wait there and in the
meantime you can do whatever you want
and once the server sends some data to
my program the program of the event loop
kind of wakes up here and I can continue
the execution
so the WebSockets programming model fits
very well with a sink il programming
model and so again while the web server
doesn't send anything to my program my
program is free to do other things for
example to process data from another
exchange or do other fancy stuff or
insert into a database in Python there's
a nice library to work with WebSockets
of course it's called WebSockets there
are version 4 already so it's kind of
kind of mature and we're gonna use this
here Oh
how does it work so this is the likely
hello world example from from WebSockets
basically instead of connecting to the
HTTP protocol we connect with the
WebSocket protocol and we have an
address and a port and basically we we
see here that I just wait from data
coming from the server so here I have
website
could receive their Aiko greeting and
then I print my greeting that's my
function and I can run it into my event
loop here exchanges so some exchanges
also support is protocol and every
exchange as their own way of connecting
to it
for example bitonic as this following
address secure web socket and then api
and so on then the version usually
version one market market for example
it's bitcoin euro and then the channel
the channel could be trade could be e or
a book and other kind of stuff to get
data from bitonic then we could say well
that's my address i want to connect
using the WebSocket and then while true
so basically just listen forever
I'll wait that is that the web server
sends you something as soon as you say I
should get something
well basically here I load the message
as a dictionary then I create a response
which I'll send to the database and then
here I say well basically a wait my
insert function is insert function is
the function that sends it sends data
into a database and again I can use a
weight here as well because I don't care
to be alive while the database is
inserting stuff I could just be set to
sleep and my event loop could do
something else so just a weight is
assertion GX is a bit more complex
because they want a subscription message
before it sends us data so in this
example we use this subscription message
basically we want to subscribe to the
Bitcoin euro channel by listening to the
ticker the ticker is basically this all
the trader that gets made and here I had
to specify again and I want to listen to
Bitcoin euros so
since I have to subscribe the means that
I also have to send data through
WebSocket so this one we didn't see that
we can say WebSocket sent and then we
send our subscribe message and once that
is done we just need to send it once
once that is done again we can wait
forever and just get data from GDX so we
are wait data the program can do other
things while no data comes in then some
data comes in we load it into message
string we convert it into a dictionary
we create a GTX response and then we
insert into our database questions up to
here okay so where we sort this data
well in the in the diagram I already
gave it away we put it into Postgres and
since we are in a syncline land and I
showed you here that our insert function
can work with it we would our a sink
code that means that I cannot use my
favorite poses client which is psycho PG
to who knows psycho PG - it's really
awesome but it doesn't work with a sink
io so I need to use something else hope
well luckily I didn't have to write it
myself but some nice folk folks wrote a
sink PG a sink G as a name the name says
is a Python async client to work with
portress well it's developed by a Python
core developer and his friend Elvis
which is the guy beyond the edge DB
that's the website where you can find a
well basically the driver and how you
use it it's also very simple you connect
to your database and then you could say
fetch me some values and close the
connection you can see here that every
time there is an
wait keyword my function could stop
having the focus until the right part of
the line has finished so every time you
see a weight here that means that other
function another good part of my code
could start doing stuff which is really
nice
well in our case we don't have to write
much to insert our data basically we get
sent to tick which is just a trade in
our case which is a name to tuple and I
extract the fields from my name tuple
and then I create basically I created my
query here it's kind of ugly and it's
worse than psycho PG too but that's
that's how the developer said you should
use it and then here so this code is
synchronous so my event loop is only
doing this one after the other but once
I hit a sing here I'm stopping up until
I get a connection from the pool and
other people could go on then I go to
the next line I stop again because I
want to start a projection and then in
the next line I wait again for the
connection to execute my query questions
here
sorry oh well yeah sure it's in the pool
so here I pass a pool object we'll see
you the code later but basically the
pool object there has all the connection
parameters to connected to my policy
yeah so yeah so the question was are the
query parameters sanitized before
insertion yeah and the answer is that
async PG doesn't do it for you like
psycho PG does sub psycho PG also allows
you to build secure and in a kind of
strange way to be super safe the async
eg doesn't do that but this is kind of
fine in the sense that I pass name to PO
which I build myself and so they're kind
of sanitized already up here of course
we're almost done we have all the older
all the things in place but one actual
detail is that we're handling time
series data and time series data it's
kind of peculiar and porters can handle
it just fine if you want but if you want
to squeeze performance a little bit more
we can use an extension on top of
Postgres which is called time scale
times care is an open source extension
an extension import westland means that
it's like a plugin so you don't have to
write a different version of pause race
you can just write the latest and the
greatest from the from a Porsche website
and install this plug-in an extension
dose in fortress parlance and Eden it
enables not only in certain time series
data more efficiently but also it gives
us some extra key words to make querying
time series data more efficient and
yeah I want to go to beat into timescale
but basically let's say you have a table
where T s is a column which is a
timestamp with time zone then you can
convert this table into a timescale
table or hyper table with this piece of
CTL here and so basically here we're
saying to to time scale my ticker table
as a column name time stamp and I want
that to become my basically my times
time stamp in my time index and then at
the end I'm gonna say optimize it for
query which are intraday it's kind of
important this intra intraday this
interval one day and why is it important
because under the hood time scale will
use partitioning so we partition the
data into in into one day interval but
you also it will also do something that
usually not all time scale well what was
doesn't do by default which is it will
order data on disk based on time stamp
even when the data does not come in in
order which is like the what happens
when you when you when you're inserting
data from multiple exchanges right so
data comes in maybe from from GDX
there's a particular timestamp but a
couple of seconds later because the
network was slow data from vitani comes
in but you won't steal them to be
ordered so time scale will reorder the
data on disk and so it makes you very
much faster and we will see some
performance numbers later of course it's
not the end of the world when you spend
to that your query spends two days but
of course if every queries asks data for
weeks then it's much better to change
your interval here and the same if your
queries are all intra our change your
interval two hours because then is much
more efficient and it's much cheaper to
reorder the data by hours yes
while you could create two tables yeah
you could create two tables right yeah
so that's all every table I mean the
underlying assumption is at every table
as kind of a time scale which is inner
it to the table and if it's mixed like
three months and two minutes then maybe
you should split them with I mean each
table should get our own time scale
table
well these already set and they have a
cool logo also what's important so for
example once we insert this data into
into our tape and to our table we could
say give me the last ask price order by
timestamp which is new portress doesn't
have lost with two arguments
it only has lost with not one argument
they give me the last bid price the last
time stamp and then the exchange for my
ticker table and then I want all
timestamp between now and one minutes
ago and I want to group by exchange so
you can see from the results here yeah
thank you you can see from the results
here that I prepare to talk and on the
11th of May because I got data from 11
from Bahia but basically this kind of
it's already a bit of logic from that we
can use later because now I want to find
arbitrage opportunities I want to find
where I kind buy low and sell high
between exchanges right so I could use a
previous query which we just wrote I
call this later sprats and then
afterwards I said well let's start from
here join later spread with itself in a
cross join so for every line of later
spread journey with all the other lines
of of later spreads so basically this
does a cross join and I get all the
exchange possibilities
and then I want the bid price from the
exchange when I want to sell mine is the
s price from where I want to buy should
be higher than the transaction cost
which usually are 0.25 percent but it
could be a parameter and just hard coded
here for convenience because of course
if the spread is lower than the
production cost is not is of no use and
you could also say transaction cost plus
0.5 percent because you want to mean
that 0.5 percent is what you want to
keep for yourself and then of course you
want the timestamp between the buy from
and the sell to to be quite close to the
error because this exchange are very
liquid and for example bitonic sometimes
only sends data only has a trade every
three minutes and gee that's much more
often so if you take the the price of
GDX now versus versus the price of
botanic three minutes ago
everything is scrambled and you cannot
make the trade so you want to limit the
interval here so these are the
conditions and then I want to select the
bid - to ask I want to basically round
the percentage this for visualization
later and then I want to know where I
should sell and what I should buy this
is already basically all the logic for
your emailer because the other part we
would insert data into the database and
then the emailer can just run this query
continuously and if there's something it
could it could return results and of
course you say well almost like kind of
a thick query how is it fast well
actually this kind of runs in 4
milliseconds and it only needs to
basically and only me to run to run on
data for a single day and data for a
single day always fits in your RAM and
the nice thing about well Postgres and x
/ and everything that as
they I mean you go to the next day you
evict the data that was in RAM with the
data of today and so it always remains
fast and of course four milliseconds is
fine because the network delay is like
to order magnet is more half a second
and these four is for a query on a table
with 50 million rows four gigabytes of
data and on the smallest and crappiest
VM google offers with a single CPU so
basically if you go yeah five so if you
go if you go higher you can get much
better results now show us a real code
Oh
sorry so let's see
okay you read yeah so basically this is
the program that inserts the data and we
get a poo here all right - you - Mike so
we get a poo here and then we say I want
to use this pool to insert data into the
ticker and I create my insert ticker
icing function and then I just say well
my dear event loop please run might get
a sinc function which is either this or
this
once you're done which is hopefully
never close the event loop did the pool
sorry and since I want this thing to run
continuously I put it into a wild true
they can kind of continue you can
continue going and this function here
again we already saw them but it is like
with logging which I didn't have in this
slide but it's basically what we already
saw insert occur with cell and maybe we
can also show the cat poo function here
we just with the trice basically tries
to get a connection to the database and
get a poo of connection from the
database and it tries 20 times and the
reason is that I'm using docker so that
means that the image that runs the
database is separated from the image
that inserts the data and it also means
that while I'm spinning up these images
the database image won't be ready
immediately so the image and inserts the
data needs to wait a bit so that's why I
have 20 attempts
the force before getting the pool
creating a docker image with this code
is very simple basically I get the one
of the latest Python and I just add my
code and people saw the packages which
are there and if I want to use it with
docker compose I say well I want an
image from my database which is the time
scale image and then I want an image to
insert bitonic data and an image to
insert gtex data and I want them to play
together so let's see if they do play
together doctor go post up can you see
you see I have a lot of exceptions
because of course we cannot connect to
the database but once the database is
ready like here that we can see that gee
Dex well be tonic is still kind of
doesn't have many traits but gee Dex
start to connect and to get these
messages here and it kind of goes on and
on and on all right now can connect to
the VM ware this is running and you can
see here it is basically the query that
I'll show you before be tweaked oh I'm
going to show you something else
yeah so you can see here for example
between bitstamp and crackin right now
is lie the time in EGC and we are in UTC
+2 so this is right now
there was a spread which was 8 so this
is a spread which is very low like
basically zero but because otherwise we
have to wait like days before spread
opens up but once this is running you
can see that these are the Reapers that
I get from the from the emailer so
basically said well at this particular
time 10 days ago there was a spread
between bitstamp a bitonic and it was a
spat at one point 45% so we have 50%
transaction cost that means that you
have zero point 95 percent of revenue is
this real of course is real but do not
use this on production if you want you
can use Blackbird and Blackbird is a
program written in C and C++ which is
much more mature but they still have a
thick disclaimer that I mean if you use
it on your own with your own money
you're on your own and then of course do
not overestimate the amount of money
that can be made because you will
destroy the order book if you just want
to go for example hundred bitcoins short
long so let's say we have a spread which
is like 80 euros and 40 euros of our
transaction costs that mean for each
Bitcoin we can make 40 euros of of
revenue so of course you want to go you
want to go short a long hundred bitcoins
shorten one exchange along in the other
and is it possible to do this I mean 100
bitcoins even at at 5000 euros per
Bitcoin you are half a million and we
don't have I don't have half a million
in the bank and of course you need to
have twice one per exchange but as I
said before we don't own these bitcoins
we are we go short and long on the
so we own the risk of market
fluctuations but since we own the risk
on both on both exchanges and with
opposite sides we oh we own the Buy and
the sell risk the risk cancel itself so
we can actually go hungry a bit going
short and long but of course the more we
short the lower the price we'll get and
the more we long the higher the price
will get so we need to tickle so we need
to buy very little while the while the
arbitrage is open and to wait basically
the price gets to its normal value so
I'll show you what this means so let's
say this is like the price is eight
thousand two hundred and ten dollars if
I by 0.001 Bitcoin but if I want to buy
97 bitcoins the price goes to a thousand
two hundred and seventy eighty dollars
so the price is much higher if I want to
buy ninety seven bitcoins on the other
hand if I want to sell ninety seven
bitcoins short sell the price won't be
this but will be eight thousand one
hundred seventy-five or something that
means that you are
you are eating your revenue if you buy
ninety seven in one time so you need to
buy a bit wait at the market stabilizes
by a bit by a bit until the arbitrage is
open basically here we want to sell to
the right guy we want to buy from the
blue guy because it's expensive but
buying here and selling here which will
push the arbitrage close would close the
arbitrage so if you do this you need to
buy very slowly
that was it thank you
[Applause]